hey everyone i got a question from one
of the people who has kind of joined my
team name arturo now let me tell you a
quick story before i get to the question
arturo has been following me on youtube
and has loved the videos and he wrote to
me and said evan
i helped translate content for people
and help people
make connections in the latin community
and i want to translate your videos from
english to spanish because there's a ton
of spanish entrepreneurs who could love
your stuff as well
and i said arturo i love
entrepreneurship i love what you're
talking about let's do this and see what
happens so he helped me create a spanish
version of my youtube channel and he
basically takes my videos and
transcribes them i love the
entrepreneurial thinking i love the new
idea so our tour wrote to me recently
and he wrote this long email but
basically what what he's doing what his
idea is let me know what you guys think
his idea here is that as an entrepreneur
himself he's desperate to find suppliers
he's desperate for help in a whole bunch
of areas to help him grow his business
okay he needs somebody to help him
create an app for example he needs
somebody to help program stuff for him
for example he's desperate he said i am
desperate to find responsible and
affordable app programmer
and his idea here is anybody who's a
believer who's a subscriber to this
channel who's on my newsletter list
chances are those people are hardworking
entrepreneurs who believe in the same
thing who would work well together and
he wants me to create some kind of form
some kind of matchmaking some kind of
way for these people to connect so you
can promote your service meet other
people who believe in the same thing
and hopefully do some business together
make some great connections now i've
known from events that i put on here in
toronto from people who are on my
newsletter list and i've met up with
people and it's been great lots of fun
uh deals have happened together uh but i
haven't thought of making this
bigger i don't know what the format
would be if it's a form or a private
member or
whatever i'm not i'm not looking to make
money off of this anyway i'm curious to
see is this something that you want you
is this something that you want to see
and how would the structure look i'm
open to your ideas
leave a comment below if you like this
video thumbs up as usual but leave a
comment below with your ideas i'm open
i'm flexible i don't have a vision yet
for how this thing might take shape and
i think it's even better for it to come
from the community if you guys don't
comment then you don't like the idea and
it dies there
that's cool too but if you like it and
you see something there you got a way to
make this work
then let me know leave it in the
comments and uh if we get enough
traction and ideas coming maybe we'll
set something up
let me know
believe
you